The overwhelming majority of prehensile tails
in nature, are round.
But seahorse tails are square.
So, what does having a square tail do for the seahorse?
To find out, researchers printed a 3D model
of a segment of the seahorse's square tail structure--
complete with vertebrae and outer skeleton.
And they pitted it against a model of a hypothetical round tail.
Hypothetical since round seahorse tails don't exist in nature.
They hit the models with a mallet,
simulating the crushing jaws of a water bird.
The square tail came out the clear winner.
Its smoothly overlapping joints made it strong and resilient,
absorbing more energy upon impact than the circular tail.
The researchers also simulated the seahorse's prehensile grasp.
The square model maintained a better grip
because it shared more surface area with the object  it was holding on to.
Future seahorse-inspired inventions could include a
flexible robotic arm for performing surgery,
rescue and exploration robots that fit into tight spaces,
and flexible, lightweight body armor--with or without a tail.